avec n'oublie le bordeaux le ministre
des finances du canada il est à toronto
bonsoir monsieur morneau et bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous pour parler de
ceux de cette prolongation de la
prestation canadienne d'urgence
pourquoi c'est important de la prolonger
est-ce qu'il ya beaucoup de gens selon
votre estimation qui ont encore besoin
de la pcu cet été mais ça c'est vraiment
de raison on a une situation où après le
premier sel semaine on va avoir un camp
des gens beaucoup de gens acquis qu'ils
vont avoir des difficultés à trouver un
travail donc nous vous avez combien voir
où on va on va voir 5,6 millions des
gens qui va finir le primaire 16
semaines au début juillet et nous savons
qu'il n'y a pas assez de travail donc
nous voulons avoir assez de support pour
les gens qui ne peuvent pas trouver un
travail
mais en même temps nous devons nous vous
nous voulons avoir à une incentive pour
les gens qui qui peut travailler d'avoir
à l'actualité de commencer donc si tous
les sites actifs aujourd'hui il y en a
pas il ya un incitatif pour des
travailleurs ou pour des gens pour
certaines personnes il ya un incitatif à
rester sur la prestation canadienne
d'urgence et non pas à retourner au
travail
mais on a on va voir aussi une autre
annonce dans les prochaines journées
au sujet de la suivante siala réel donc
les deux programmes doivent travailler
ensemble mais nous savons que pour
plusieurs secteurs on va avoir
on vraiment continuation des défis comme
le secteur culturel par exemple nous
savons que qu'il a des artistes et
autres qui n'ont pas la possibilité de
trouver un travail
mais en même temps on sait qu'avec le
souvent sans salaire réel on peut avoir
les initiatives qui va aider les
entreprises d'avoir la possibilité de
d'avoir un touriste en train de
travailler donc pourquoi ne pas
prolonger la pcu avec des restrictions
en disant par exemple pour le secteur
culturel
nous prolongeons les prestations
canadiennes d'urgence mais pour d'autres
secteurs on ne prolonge pas la
prestation canadienne d'urgence
c'est très difficile à choisir les
factures par exemple ce acteurs aérienne
c'est une bombe à bon exemple mais il ya
aussi des compagnies qui ont comme
clients les compagnies comme air canada
donc c'est pas qu'une secteur c'est les
autres compagnies à travers le compagnie
donc on pense que la proche et de
probation pour le plonger le prestations
que les lignes d'urgence mais bien sûr
on va considérer le main de situation
d'un autre noah marché de deux
travailleurs prendre les prochaines
semaines mais même temps d'avoir une
subvention salariale qui ont des
changements qui va assurer les
entreprises qu'ils peuvent continuer
avec lui
est-ce que vous pensez que en
prolongeant les pc je comprends que ça
va aider beaucoup de gens mais en même
temps est-ce que ça va ralentir la
reprise économique
c'est toujours une équilibre je suis
vraiment d'accord mais on doit assurer
que les gens qui n'ont pas assez de
travail on le support nécessaire donc ça
c'était notre bout et avec avec les deux
mesures avec les deux programmes
je pense qu'on va avoir plus
d'initiatives pour les organisations de
de trouver une façon d'utiliser leur
emploi et ça c'est très important
mais même temps pour les gens qui ont
besoin de support à ce prêt va être là
le coup jusqu'à maintenant de la pcu on
a vu 43 milliards de dollars prolongée
la prestation jusqu'au 29
ou pour bien des gens ça va coûter
combien on est en train de faire les
chiffres bien sûr ça va être moins
chaque semaine parce qu'on pense qu'on
va avoir
une reprise prudente de notre économie
donc il ya un changement mais quand même
c'est un programme qui est qui est
vraiment chère mais nous savons que en
période de crise c'est nécessaire
d'avoir les supports nécessaires mais de
cette façon je crois avec leurs reprises
trous d'eau considéré comment nous
pouvons améliorer notre économie et ça
ça va diminuer le coût de le programme
est ce qu'il n'est pas venu le temps
pour le gouvernement du canada de
déposer un budget ou une mise à jour
économique
nous sommes le 16 juin et l'exercice est
commencée depuis le 1er avril au nom de
la transparence pour les canadiens et
les parlementaires canadiens
pourquoi vous ne disposez pas un budget
ou une mise à jour budgétaire
c'est une à c'est une question très
important nous voulons être transparents
vrai qu'avec nos investissements bien
sûr et nous voulons assurer les
canadiennes que nous avons à une bonne
situation économique le nôtre bil'in
continue d'être bon mais le défi pour
nous et d'assurer que nous avons
confiance dans nos chiffres donc avec la
situation à avril et mai alors que les
grands changements dans la situation
économique s'était trop tôt pour avoir
assez d'informations mais comme nous
pensons que ça va être plus stables dans
les prochaines les prochaines périodes
j'espère qu'on peut avoir plus à dire
mais mais c'est clair chaque chaque
journée on considère les mesures qu'on a
utilisées pour pour notre économie en ce
période
et chaque fois il ya un changement dans
le prix on est transparent et on va
continuer avec cette proche même fille
femmes 1 il ya beaucoup d'incertitudes
vous êtes capable au ministère des
finances de publier des prévisions de
publier des chiffres on a passé une
bonne partie de la crise est-ce qu'une
mise à jour budgétaire sera déposé avant
le 30 juin
on va continuer avec notre proche comme
la situation et de jeu réagir plus
stable on va considérer ce qu'on peut
faire
mais bien sûr on doit considérer les
prises prudent dans chaque province
chaque territoire
pour assurer que nous avons les chiffres
qu'on peut avoir un niveau de confiance
dans la situation et ça c'est ça c'est
notre approche mais mais c'est une c'est
toujours une bombe à bon en jeu d'être
transparent va qu'avec nos chiffres et
nous continuons d'accès c'est ce que
nous espérons de votre part monsieur
borno merci beaucoup
ok merci beaucoup et bonne journée